[تصفيق]
بيئه سياسيه للجمهوريين تحت ظنها
ولايه يوهامشير مؤخرا الولايه المتارجه
عاده بين الحزبين فرغ ما ضمان
الديمقراطيين لمقعد مجلس الشيوخ فيها
بالاشهر الاخيره اتضح انها احدى افضل فرص
الجمهوريين لسحب البساط من تحت اقدام
منافسهم وحسم المعركه لصالحهم لا سيمانا
تقدم السنه الديمقراطيه الحاليه ماجي حسن
يتقلص تدريجيا لصالح المرشح الجمهوري
العسكري المتقاعد غامبول المتخلف عنها
بنقطتين فقط وفق احدث استطلاعات الراي هذه
التطورات دفعت الجمهوريين لاعاده التركيز
على السباق المتقارب قبل انتخابات التجديد
النصفي وضخ المزيد من الاموال لدعم بولدوج
والاخير حمل ملفات نفسها التي تسيطر على
المزاج العامل الناخبين في اي الجريمه
والتضخم لكسب التاييد وتعزيز موقعه
غير ان الديمقراطيين يشككون بامكانيه قلب
منافسهم للمعادله متذرعين بان اهمال حمله
بولدوج بدايه وسحب الاموال منها للانفاق
في بنسلفانيا وغيرها بعثت برساله
لجمهوريين يوهامبر بعدم الثقه بمرشحهم كما
يستبعد بعض الديمقراطيين احداث ما سموها
باموال اللحظه الاخيره والاستثمار
المتاخره بمرشح الجمهوريين لاي فرق بسباق
الولايه
ثانيه كاسنه في وتعد معركتها هذه نسخه
لتلك التي خاضتها عام 2016 حين تمكنت من
قلب المقعد من الاحمر الازرق بفارق الف
صوت تقريبا هوامش ضيقه للفوز هذه المره
ايضا يميزها حجم الانفاق الكبير فقط والذي
يفوق منافسها باكثر من سبعه ملايين دولار
[موسيقى]